families taking loved ones to their
final resting place
is a scene that's become all too common
in lima
cemeteries have been filling up but
until now
not all deaths due to copper 19 were
included in the official figures
that's been blamed on a lack of testing
now the government has revised these
figures the death toll has more than
doubled to 180
000 since the start of the pandemic
meaning peru
has the highest coveted 19 death rate
per capita
of anywhere in the world
we consider our duty to publish this
updated information
not only as part of our commitment with
accountability but also to fulfill our
responsibilities as a state
an already underfunded healthcare system
has become
overwhelmed many hospitals are running
out of oxygen supplies
signs the situation was far worse than
officially reported
peru has only tested about one-third of
proportionally of its population so when
you do not have access to testing you
shouldn't just be counting
people who have tested positive and who
eventually died of kovit because of
course
a great number of people won't be
being counted in those figures other
experts say politics is taking a part in
under-reporting numbers to make
short-term gains
if you're going to undersell these
numbers in order to gain some short-term
wins from politics
you're going to lose at the at the
long-term mother nature is not political
she has her own agenda if you do this to
lie about the numbers
mother nature won't right we will see
those those unfortunate cemeteries and
burial sites that we see throughout the
world you cannot
hide that despite the revised mortality
figures
the government says it's not planning to
speed up its vaccination programme
there shouldn't be a need to change for
other policies including vaccination
or any other in terms of decisions
with peru experiencing its deadliest
periods since the start of the pandemic
even the cemeteries are becoming
overwhelmed
many now running out of space to bury
the dead
laura berdiman the al jazeera